perché sur sa colline à Bazoches sur
Guyenne la Maison Louis Carré a
accueilli une invité de marque Nathalie
Junot Ponsard l'artiste a investi les
lieux avec 42 créations on peut voir
dans l'entrée cette vague en bleu indigo
foncé et orange transparent qui est une
réponse au toit de la maison donc ce
matériau est transparent il prend la
lumière et au fur et à mesure de la
journée du soleil qui tourne autour de
la maison il va projeter des ombres
chromatiques colorées dans l'espace
sculpture en verre photographie ou
encore
œuvre lumineuse Nathalie travaille en
fonction des lieux son fil conducteur la
lumière et ses longueurs d'ondes ici
rien n'est placé au hasard je cherche à
produire une sorte d'influence de la
lumière par mes œuvres sur sur le
visiteur la lumière solaire elle nous
influence du matin au soir et suivant
les latitudes autour de la
on peut voir une oeuvre en verre et
chromatique
éclairée rétroéclairé face à un tapis
qui est posé au sol et qui représente
donc de la lumière colorée et qui nous
donne la sensation de pouvoir marcher
sur la couleur et la lumière classée au
monument historique depuis 1996 la
Maison Louis Carré et le seul bâtiment
conçu en France par le designer et
architecte Alvar alto elle appartenait
au collectionneurs d'art Louis Carré
c'était une maison où le couple carré
vive et en permanence c'était un lieu où
il mettait en valeur sa collection ces
artistes la galerie c'est une villa qui
qui était vivante qui était bien connue
à l'époque
et qui aujourd'hui retrouve un petit peu
cette vie là
[Musique]
j'ai désiré à nouveau investir la baie
vitrée cette fois-ci avec une
chromatique orange qui pour moi
correspond au lieu et qui nous va nous
donner également une perception
changeante de l'extérieur et de nuit
l'inverse depuis l'extérieur une autre
perception de la salle à manger
ce que nous savons choisir c'est de
d'exposer de la contemporain ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que quel que soit
le médium ça marche c'est ça qui est
magique avec l'architecture d'avoir alto
l'exposition solaire est accessible
jusqu'au 27 novembre
[Musique]